LINNEA SHIVELY: Good evening.
My name is Linnea Shively,
and I'm a freshman here
at Hillsdale College intending
to major in political economy
and minor in journalism.
It's an honor to introduce
our speaker tonight.
Christopher F. Rufo is a
Senior Fellow at the Manhattan
Institute and
Founder and Director
of Battlefront, a public
policy research center.
Author of the recent Imprimis
essay, Critical Race Theory--
What It Is and How
To Fight It, he
is a graduate of
Georgetown University
and a former Lincoln
Fellow at the Claremont
Institute for the Study of
Statesmanship and Political
Philosophy.
As Executive Director at
the Documentary Foundation,
he has directed four films for
PBS, including, most recently,
America Lost,
which explores life
in Youngstown, Ohio, Memphis,
Tennessee, and Stockton,
California.
He is also a contributing
editor of City Journal
where he covers topics
including critical race
theory, homelessness,
addiction, and crime.
Please join me in
welcoming Mr. Rufo.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTOPHER RUFO: All right.
How is everyone?
[AUDIENCE MURMURS]
Good.
Good to meet you.
I think I see some of my
students from this last week.
I've been teaching a
one-credit journalism class.
All of the students present
will get an A in the class,
so congratulations.
[LAUGHTER]
Over there, well done.
Well, let's see what we can do.
Let's get in some
trouble tonight maybe.
I know that this is being
recorded and livestreamed,
so I'm hoping to say something
interesting and noteworthy
in the next 30 minutes or so.
The topic tonight is Laying
Siege to the Institutions.
And so the question is,
what does that mean?
But before we can
answer that question,
we have to know the context
in which that question must
be asked.
And so I'd like us to take
a step back to the period
that none of you remember--
you're all far too young--
the period of 1968.
[LAUGHTER]
If you look at
1968, it was really
a paradoxical and
contradictory turning point
in American history.
You had, then, all of the
left-wing ideologies that
seemed so dominant
in our institutions
today being born in the
months in and around 1968.
You had the birth of
identity politics.
You had the idea that the United
States could be overthrown
through cultural revolution.
And then you had the very
beginnings of militant street
activists that had sought
to, what they believed,
use urban guerrilla
warfare to achieve
their political objectives.
And I think many of
the stories that I
work on, many of the
phenomena that we see,
many of the public policies that
some of our friends on the far
left in places like Seattle,
or San Francisco, or New
York, or Chicago are
proposing, if you actually
look back and look
at the literature,
look at the manifestos, look at
the publications of that era,
you see a remarkable similarity.
It's almost as if we're living
in permanent repeat of some
of those ideas.
The only difference,
unfortunately,
is that, in 1968, it was
also the year that was
the election of Richard Nixon--
not exactly a
fire-breathing leftist.
And so you saw this left wing
movement burn out over time.
By the mid-1970s, the groups
like the Black Panther Party,
the Black Liberation Army,
the Weather Underground,
or their counterparts
in Europe--
in Germany, and Italy,
and other countries--
that had sought to
really capitalize
on what they saw as a world
historical change in 1968
had met really a
sad and divided end.
They were infiltrated
by law enforcement.
Their campaign for
urban guerrilla warfare
generated discontent,
especially in the communities
that they claimed to represent.
And so, by the end
of it, there was just
a few dozen angry,
disillusioned, demoralized
radicals.
The FBI had swept
up many of them.
And what you sense
in the literature
and the history of the time--
and you can read it in all
of the journalistic work,
the letters, the essays,
some of the academic work,
is that they realized that
this moment had been lost.
They looked at it as the
victory of counter-revolutionary
forces, embodied most
prominently in the United
States by Richard Nixon.
But really, at the
heart of it, the lesson
that they learned at the time
was that the working class
in the West--
in Western Europe and especially
in the United States--
could not be roused
to revolution.
That class-based
idea that you could
have the suppressed workers
or the oppressed workers
rise up against their bosses
in the factories in places
like Detroit,
Michigan was doomed.
And, in fact,
working-class Americans
were not only non-revolutionary,
they were anti-revolutionary.
They were actually satisfied
with a rapidly rising standard
of living, with benefits and
privileges that their parents
and grandparents could not
have even imagined, perhaps,
when they were immigrating from
Europe in the decades prior.
And so this immense frustration,
by the time you hit the 1970s,
is really evident at all
of the work of the period.
And so they settled on a
strategy of the long march
through the institutions.
They realized that they
couldn't set off bombs
in the US Capitol, as they tried
to do, or assassinate police
officers, shooting them in
the back of the head at point
blank range in New
York City, as they
had done a number of times.
But they actually formulated
a new, more sophisticated,
and, frankly, very successful
strategy of abandoning
hope that the
lumpen proletariat--
so the outcasts of society,
people who are truly
the downtrodden and forgotten
remnants of the American class
system, they really abandoned
hope that they could
be part of this revolution.
They said, we're going
to go a revolution
of the intelligentsia,
a revolution of elites,
by seizing control of not
of the means of production--
you'd be hard pressed to
get some academics running
a factory line in Detroit--
but through the means of culture
and knowledge production.
And so what you see is
these washed-up radicals,
in the '60s, '70s, early-'80s,
migrating into academia,
and then bringing their ideas,
for example, in the 1970s,
out of the radical manifestos,
the Marxist-Leninist
revolutionary manifestos, and
into formalized academic work.
What I've done-- we're
going to fast forward,
we have a limited
amount of time--
but what I've done
in the last two years
is report on the state of
our institutions today.
I've looked at the
federal government.
I've looked at the universities.
I've looked at
Fortune 100 companies.
And I've looked at K
through 12 schools.
And what I found is
something that I think
is shocking to most Americans.
You're taking the core
concepts that were developed
in that period after 1968.
They've been sanitized, adapted,
repackaged, and repurposed,
and then injected
into American life
at the lateral, bureaucratic,
and institutional level.
So you have an idea that seems
somewhat frivolous, maybe
somewhat ridiculous, like
white privilege, that's
being taught, in many
stories that I've
reported on, to kids as young as
seven, eight, nine years old--
that children in a classroom
can be separated into oppressor
and oppressed based on
identity categories,
based on skin color, and then
deemed oppressor and oppressed.
And then the kids in the
public classroom, let's say,
in Cupertino, California-- they
recently did this for third
graders--
should atone for
their white privilege.
Some of it seems a little goofy.
It seems a little
bit ridiculous.
But the origins of
white privilege theory,
again, were from 1968.
It was a
Marxist-Leninist theory.
The idea is that you'd
have to break down
working-class notions of white
privilege in order for them
to join the Marxist revolution.
And so the purpose and
the origins of a lot
of these ideas, as
you go down the line,
all emerges from that
point and now has
been transferred through
academic literature,
through K-through-12
pedagogy, through masters
in education programs, through
K-through-12 curriculum
modules, through HR programs--
human resources departments--
at corporations.
And I think what we
find ourselves in
is a maze of postmodern language
that is the other element that
is grafted onto the
revolutionary rhetoric of 60,
70 years ago now.
And it's a language
of obfuscation,
it's a language of
euphemism, and it's
a language of demoralization.
And so as many of you have
been following, for example,
the fight against critical
race theory, one of the fights
that has been really
going on for a year,
almost to the
point of absurdity,
is this euphemistic
game of, well,
what is critical race theory?
That's not critical race theory.
Critical race theory is an
obscure legal theory only found
in upper-division
law school classes.
Oh, well, your K through
12 elementary curriculum
says critical race
theory on the cover?
It's using all the principles
of critical race theory?
That couldn't be.
It couldn't exist.
That's diversity,
equity, and inclusion.
And so you get these ideas that
are wrapped in language that
is meant to obscure
or meant to be
impenetrable or un-opposable.
I think none of us, very
few people, certainly,
in the United States--
and to a lesser extent,
but also in the world--
would oppose diversity in
the true sense of the word,
meaning having a
variety of experiences,
interacting with a
different variety of people.
This is why Americans travel.
This is why you go overseas.
You want to get a
diversity of perspective,
and culture, opinion, history.
That's not what it means
in practice, though.
The next term, equity,
it appeals to this idea
that's a homonym with equality.
And yet the significance of
it is the exact opposite.
Equality is the idea
that each individual
should be protected
under the law
regardless of characteristics
that might be separating them
into different groups
or categories, this idea
that no matter who you
are, where you come from,
you'll be treated
equally under the law.
Equity takes the opposite view.
It would replace the
system of individual rights
with the system of group
identity-based rights, in that
your merit, or your
worth, or your position,
or the material resources
that are divided and then
distributed, should be based not
on your individual potential,
or character, or work,
or accomplishment,
but based on your
group identity that
takes no account of your
individual characteristics
or excellence.
And so what I've tried
to do in my reporting
is to surface all of these
very dense and very euphemistic
phrases and terms
that you're probably
seeing popping up everywhere.
You're probably
seeing it at work.
You might be seeing it in
your kids' K-through-12 school
curriculum.
You're certainly seeing it
in the political sphere.
And our federal government is
absolutely saturated with it.
And it's trying to
make heads or tails.
It's trying to make
sense of this language.
It's trying to get to the
heart of what these words mean,
because I think that
only then you can truly
have a sense of how
you can defeat it,
how you can fight back.
Because what I've seen, over
and over, in my reporting,
looking at original
source documents,
is that every elite
institution in the country that
has dominance over knowledge,
dominance over culture,
dominance over even, in many
cases, material production,
has converged on a
unitary ideology.
It's really a remarkable thing.
The HR training program
at Walmart, for example,
is the same as the
fifth-grade education
module in Buffalo
public schools,
is the same as the diversity
and inclusion training
program at the Department of
the Treasury in Washington, DC.
All three examples
from my reporting.
And it's a very basic list of
concepts derived, in this case,
from critical race
theory, that says
the United States is
fundamentally an irredeemably
a racist country.
The country, today, is saturated
through with systemic racism.
In the racial categorization of
citizens in the here and now,
it can be divided on
the axis of oppressor
and oppressed based on race.
And people who are deemed
white or, in some cases,
white enough-- like
Asian-Americans, strangely--
you have to atone
for your privilege,
you have to bankrupt
your privilege,
and then if you want to be
re-accepted back into society
after that process,
you have to submit
to the political ideology
that regards not freedom
and equality, not the
Constitution, not the principle
of equal protection,
not even the system
of individual rights,
but moving to a system
of collective
group-based rights,
moving to a system that is
explicitly anti-capitalist.
You have organizations,
for example,
like American Express
preaching that capitalism
is fundamentally racist--
American Express
teaching that capitalism
is fundamentally racist
and so on and so forth.
And one of the great
curiosities for me
was, how is this even possible?
I'm sorting through documents
from 5,000 different sources,
all over the country, from
every kind of institution,
from all walks of life.
How is it possible that
it's been distilled down
to these key, say,
seven to 10 ideas that
are then implanted
into the organizations
through the bureaucracy?
So it's either the
DEI bureaucracy--
that's kind of the
most common one now--
human resources is
another one, there's
all sorts of
different euphemisms
that get constantly
created and recreated.
But the ideology is the same.
And the ideology is
really indistinguishable,
at its essence, from a
lot of those materials
that we saw in 1968.
And so the question is, what
can we do to fight back?
I'm going to talk
about tactics and then
about strategy.
As far as tactics, I've
been tasked and asked
to talk a little
bit about a story
that I broke last week while
I was teaching the journalism
students here at Hillsdale
College about a company
called Walt Disney.
So any news watchers
in the room?
Yeah, OK.
So you've probably heard
about this scandal,
really, with the
Walt Disney Company.
I've actually been reporting
on Walt Disney for more
than a year, off and on.
I have some good sources
inside the company.
I broke a story last year
that Walt Disney Company
was forcing employees to engage
in a critical race theory
training program which
denounced the United
States as a fundamentally
racist country,
asked its white employees to
complete a white privilege
checklist, and then
advocated for all
of the fashionable causes.
I believe they had
exercises in there
to decolonize your bookshelf,
whatever that means.
And any kind of these
pedagogical techniques or kind
of fashionable
self-reflection exercises
that you see in all
of these corporations,
Disney was doing it.
After I broke the story,
Disney's first attempt
was to deflect.
They sent out this amazing
press release, actually.
They said-- because people
were criticizing-- they said,
this is racist.
You're dividing your employees
along the basis of race.
They've created
racially-segregated employee
activist groups.
They're denouncing the country.
They're denouncing a large
part of their employees
and their customers on
the basis of skin color.
And Disney said in
a press release,
no, no, no, we
can't be racist, we
made the movie Black Panther.
Which is a kind of bizarre
corporate variation
on the old joke about,
I can't be racist,
I have Black friends.
It was really a kind
of ridiculous moment
where they were
caught, you could see,
between the lines of the press
release, totally off-guard.
Because in the
elite milieu, this
is something that is
not even questioned.
In fact, the Disney employees
who leaked me these documents
and then the video said,
you cannot question them.
You can't say a word.
You have to be silent.
This is the new orthodoxy.
This is the orthodoxy in
every elite institution.
If you want to keep your
job, you have to shut up.
Disney eventually deleted
their entire program
from their internal website--
so a big victory for me.
That's always fun.
But, of course, these things
get deleted temporarily,
but they always resurface.
Because it's not that it
was well-intentioned people,
that they made a
mistake, or they
had a document in their server
or part of their training
program that they
didn't agree with.
These things are baked
into the bureaucracy.
And so last week, I was
sent a full video, an hour
and 40 minutes, approximately,
of Disney's internal meetings
regarding its very
political and very public
fight with the
governor of Florida,
a man named Ron DeSantis,
who signed a bill--
I think a very simple bill--
that simply said you
have to keep education
on gender ideology,
sexual orientation,
and sexuality out
of the classroom
between the ages of
kindergarten and third grade.
This seems fairly commonsense.
I think it has, depending on
the polling question, somewhere
between 60% and 80% support,
an overwhelming number
of Americans.
But the activist
groups within Disney
were furious,
because they believe
that Disney, as the world's
largest entertainment
corporation, certainly
the largest entertainment
corporation in human history
regarding kids' entertainment,
they believe that they were
the moral voice on children
and sexuality and that they
wanted to not only oppose
the legislation, but use all of
the levers of corporate power
to fundamentally reshape
the narrative about kids
and sexuality.
And so I released a series
of videos last week that had,
for example, an executive
producer saying that she was
deliberately, with the
support of her colleagues,
inserting what she
called a, quote,
"not-so-secret gay agenda"
into kids programming,
targeting kids as
young as two years old.
Another Disney employee,
a production coordinator,
said that he had created a
tracking program to make sure
that the company was including
enough transgender, non-binary,
and asexual characters.
I think I have
those terms right.
And this whole
series of statements,
which you might imagine
happening at, maybe,
the Women's Studies
department at Vassar College
I think rightly
concerned a lot of people
when it was high-level
executives saying,
we are going to
fundamentally change
the relationship between
kids and sexuality
in the United States by
engineering a narrative based
on gender ideology.
We're going to do
so really secretly--
they didn't make an
announcement about this--
while, at the same
time, we're going
to be publicly opposing
any legislation that
would provide a restriction
on this in public schools.
And so this was, in short, I
think, a scandal for Disney.
They were very tough.
They were kind of chest-beating.
Executives had gone out, prior
to this story, saying what they
were going to do, talking
trash to the governor,
committing to overthrowing
this bill and overturning it.
And then after they
were really pummeled--
I think Fox News mentioned this
story 300 times in 24 hours
at one point last week--
the New York Times
wrote about it.
They said, this was all
fine until Chris Rufo
got a hold of it.
Tried to blame me for it.
And then the company
went fairly silent.
I think it probably also has
something to do with those poll
numbers we talked about, where
a huge majority of not just
Florida voters, but American
voters, American adults, said,
hey, wait a minute,
this is too much.
We don't want to have
gender ideology being taken
from the university and being
forced on kindergarteners
behind the backs of parents
without informing them
about what's going on.
And this is something
we've seen over and over
and over, whether it's critical
race theory or gender ideology.
And so I think we've
struck quite a blow.
Disney was trending on
Twitter-- which is, I think,
kind of a distorted
approximation
for what's in the
news, in some ways--
for an entire week.
You had conservatives
boycotting, canceling
Disney subscriptions.
Anyone cancel a Disney
subscription in the last week?
OK, good.
That's at least $500
a month or whatever.
You had a lot of
people canceling,
and I think you had a lot
of Americans really raising
questions--
what's happening with
our institutions?
What's happening with kids?
I also discovered that,
playing a bit of hardball,
when a company enters
the political debate
on the issues of
children and sexuality,
my argument was that,
well, we should actually
examine their record on
children and sexuality.
And to my somewhat
surprise, I found out
that the Walt Disney Company
has had a notorious pattern,
at least once a year
for the last decade,
and then before that as
well, of having employees
arrested for child sex crimes--
child pornography, child
exploitation, child rape,
et cetera.
And not only that-- that's
obviously bad enough--
it appears from the
coverage that it
is a disproportionate number.
The Polk County Sheriff, who's
adjacent to Disney's operations
in Orlando, Florida, it
seems like every time
he does a sex sting, he nabs at
least a few Disney employees,
disproportionate,
I would imagine,
based on the limited
evidence, to their rate
in the labor force.
And so my point is that,
when a company is claiming
the moral high ground on
these issues of children
and sexuality, we should
look at their record.
And of course, they're not
responsible for everything
their employees do
on their own time.
But I also found a
few stories as well.
Disney authorities allegedly
told their cruise ship security
guard to keep her mouth
shut when she discovered
that one of the Disney
employees was molesting
a young boy on the
cruise ship, which
allowed him to evade arrest.
And then Disney flew
him back home to India
so he couldn't stand
to be accountable.
And also, Disney's cruise
ship lobbyist association,
the trade association,
of which Disney
is a member, had advocated
against, had opposed,
and then significantly
watered down
legislation that
would have required
Disney and other
cruise lines to report
sexual abuse on its cruise
ships in a timely and stringent
manner.
And so I think the lesson of
this is that the institutions
in the United States that have
adopted these ideologies cannot
be appeased.
They can't be easily
shifted from within.
They've been captured at
the bureaucratic level.
And Disney has the
perfect case study.
Disney executives have
delegated moral authority
within the company and
political authority
within the company to internal
activist organizations,
whether they're in the race
and sex-segregated identity
caucuses or in the human
resources departments.
And so what it's
going to require
is not a long march
through the institutions.
I think most conservatives don't
have the ambition of, one day,
being a diversity and equity
director at a public school
district, whatever
that might look like.
So the strategy is not to say,
well, let's march back in,
let's have a kind
of counter-march,
I think the strategy
is quite different.
It's an actual siege strategy.
It's from the outside.
And it's taking on our
superior public support.
Because whether it's critical
race theory or gender
ideology in schools,
for example,
we have about a 2-to-1
margin, the public
supporting our position
and opposing the position
of the institutions.
These institutions don't
choose these ideologies
democratically.
You didn't vote for it.
I didn't vote for it.
They're imposed
anti-democratically by fiat
through bureaucratic,
not democratic, rule.
And so what we're
seeing, I think,
as the first step is a
narrative and symbolic war
against companies like
Disney, for one example.
You have to be very aggressive.
You have to fight on
terms that you define.
You have to create your own
frame, your own language,
and you have to be
ruthless and brutal
in pursuit of something good.
The second strategy is
mobilizing popular support.
We're seeing this at
school board level.
After the reporting that I did
and some other colleagues have
then picked up on about critical
race theory in public schools,
I saw this amazing emergence,
organically, of irate parents
coming home from work, tired,
in their dress clothes,
showing up at those
school board meetings
and giving hell to those
school board officials.
Did you see any of these videos?
Yeah.
And we know for a fact that
these parents didn't know what
was happening in the classroom.
They never voted or
approved of this.
And when they found out what
was happening, they were livid.
And so parents are getting
mobilized on that grassroots
level to oppose this kind
of ideological capture
in those K-through-12
school districts.
And when they won't listen,
which is much of the time,
parents who have organized
and run campaigns
are winning
overwhelming elections--
we're talking 70-30.
If you put your name on the
ballot in the median school
district in the United
States and you say,
I'm the anti-critical
race theory candidate,
I'm going to get our
education system back
to the basics of reading,
writing, math, et cetera,
prioritizing excellence
over ideology,
you're going to win, in many
places, at that 70-30 level,
I think reflecting
overwhelming public support.
And I think the third step,
then, is to decentralize.
Because a lot of
these problems emerge
because of centralization,
because of bureaucratic rule,
because of control by a
minority of permanently
publicly-subsidized
activists that
have turned public institutions
into private ideological
organizations.
And I think, when
you look at schools
as another good example--
we can talk about
universities, maybe,
if we have a little time--
but when you talk
about schools, there's
no reason that, if
you're a parent,
you don't have the
means, let's say,
to send your kid to private
school or parochial school,
that you should be stuck
in a public school,
based on your zip code,
that violates your child's
right to conscience, that
shames or demoralizes
your child on the basis
of race or identity,
and that you're
allowed no recourse
through the bureaucracy
and no escape mechanism.
There's no reason
why we can't have,
for example, universal
school choice
so that a family that says, you
know what, this isn't for me;
this violates our family's
values at a deep level,
shouldn't be able to take
that average of $15,000 a year
and move it wherever they want.
It could be another
public school,
it could be a charter school,
it could be a private school.
This is controversial--
I don't know why--
but it could also be
to a religious school.
Because what's
happening is that you
have 90% of American
schoolchildren attending
public =, you have 90% of
American university students
attending public universities.
You have a monopoly that, unless
it's broken up, unless parents
are given more power, more
freedom, more options,
more choice, they're
going to be forced
to run their kids
through a gauntlet
that they can't control.
And so I think if you
categorize them all together,
to summarize very
briefly, you're
engaging in a narrative war.
I mentioned earlier that
there's this kind of postmodern
layering on top of all of
our institutions to turn the,
let's say, revolutionary
ideology into something
very gauzy, very vague, very
seductive, very attractive,
soft language.
We have to rip that veil
off of what's happening
and show Americans, through
reporting, through information,
through investigation, through
public records requests,
et cetera, exactly
what's happening.
And we have to fight at that
narrative and symbolic level.
We live in an
information society.
And if we are unilaterally
outmanned on that front,
it's impossible
to gain traction.
Someone could go to the
school board meeting
and literally not have the words
to oppose what's happening.
And so that's what
I've tried to do,
what others are now also
doing, is providing people
a kind of key into explaining,
beyond the euphemism, exactly
what's happening,
what those words mean,
ripping the cover
off of that language
and providing them with
a renewed moral language
to be waging the fight,
not within the confines
of the opposition's framing,
but by creating a new frame.
And so with critical
race theory,
for example, it creates
an entirely new frame.
You're fighting substantively,
accurately, but also
with language that
you can point to,
you can go to a school board
meeting, you can explain,
and you can oppose.
And the evidence shows that,
from polling data that's been
done sequentially over the
last 18 months, 18 months ago,
let's say two years
ago-- round up--
0% of the American people knew
about critical race theory.
In the last 18 months,
we've brought that number up
to 75% of the American people.
And we've turned it into
a 2-to-1 issue, which,
in politics--
I don't know how many
of you are in politics--
if you go to, let's say, a
campaign manager and you say,
hey, we have a 2-to-1 issue--
they're going to be salivating,
and drooling, and calling in ad
buys immediately.
That's a decisive victory in an
otherwise fairly evenly-divided
society.
The second is to attack the
credibility of institutions.
This is something that I think
conservatives have been rightly
hesitant to do for many years.
But we like our institutions.
I think conservatives
are really realizing now,
we like what our
institutions were.
We like what we
imagine them to be.
And now that we are
seeing what they are,
we don't like them as much.
And so, luckily,
the institutions
are really doing
this to themselves.
You see trust in all of
our institutions cratering.
I think it's foolhardy
to say, well,
we really want to just
raise that number.
I think you want to
create the conditions
for fundamental,
structural change,
to appropriate some language.
For example, school choice--
to get universal school
choice, you really
need to operate from a premise
of universal public school
distrust.
Because in order for people
to take significant action,
they have to feel like they
have something at stake.
I think that the public schools
have done a remarkable job
at doing that--
specifically the public
school teachers unions.
They shut down schools
for more than a year.
In some districts,
half of all kids
never showed up to
online learning.
They've had the most
catastrophic learning
loss likely since World War II.
They kept kids masked for
years while the adults traveled
around the world
with no mask on.
And the teachers union endorsed
promoting critical race theory
in all 14,000 local
school districts.
And I think, finally, and
the positive side of this,
is we have to
create alternatives.
I think that in
a dynamic society
like the society
that we have, we also
have the opportunity
and the responsibility
to create alternatives.
And in many cases, I
think many of us have,
and many parents, for example--
I include myself in this
for a while, not anymore--
got complacent.
Well, I'll send
my kids to school.
Should be fine, kind of
like what I had growing up.
And I just don't think that
that's a realistic option
for people anymore.
And when I talk to parents, for
example, all over the country,
they're desperate for
new ideas, new options.
You have, now, 5 million
American kids in home school.
There's just been an
explosion in homeschooling.
You have even the
Hillsdale charter
schools that are now expanding.
Parents are desperate for
intellectual entrepreneurship
in a sense, political
entrepreneurship,
rather than just simply
fighting about who
gets what, actually creating
something substantive that
matches people's values.
And so before we
take questions, I'd
just like to close by
repeating the stakes,
by resetting the stakes, rather.
I really think that
the key dynamic for us
to all be thinking
about is not necessarily
even a left-versus-right
dynamic.
It is that.
That's important.
But I think where
the opportunity
lies is really a
top-and-bottom dynamic, so
a kind of elite
class that represents
a very small amount of people
that has positions of influence
within the kind of
knowledge-making institutions,
within pedagogical
institutions, that has designed,
and implemented, and
distributed all of these ideas
that we're finding
in the reporting,
and the vast majority
of the American people
who are still
attached to the idea
that America is
a force for good,
that their kids
should be protected
from radical ideologies being
imposed on them at the tender
ages of elementary
school, for example,
and that our country, in some
ways, has gone off the rails.
And they want a
sense of security.
They want a sense that
people are fighting for them.
And I really think there's
a common intuition of all
of the good that
can still be raised
into our institutions,
raised into our country,
maybe not in the exact way that
it looks now, but in the way
that it could be.
And so I really think
it's up to all of us.
You could be maybe on offense.
There's some of us, I think me
included, that really are just
built for offense.
And there's some that are built
for creating institutions,
for playing defense,
for protecting
the civilizational
values and virtues that
should be continued from
the past into the future.
And I think that if we
are just taking these two
poles, these two systems,
these two worldviews,
we really have an option
between the revolution of 1776
or the revolution of 1968.
And I think one of
them offers a method
for this incredible unfolding
of those founding principles
of freedom and equality,
and the other one
ends up in nihilism and
despair and demoralization.
It ends up in a bombed-out
bunker in Greenwich Village
in the 1970s.
And so I would suggest
to you, even some of you
who may not be
temperamentally predisposed,
that the best strategy
in the immediate term
is the siege of
the institutions,
and that we should
prepare for the fight.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
LINNEA SHIVELY:
Thank you, Mr. Rufo.
We will now have time
for some questions.
If you have a brief question,
please make your way
to a microphone.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you so much
for your talk, Chris.
CHRISTOPHER RUFO: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I want to
touch on something
that you said here in your
talk about narrative warfare.
One of the biggest problems
I think we face right now
is social media censorship.
So you broke this story
about Disney on Twitter.
And, obviously, you have
a lot of clout there
and the story can
spread like wildfire.
And it's obviously a
weapon that the left
can use is to simply silence
those voices they don't like.
And so in some ways, it
feels that the position
in the narrative
war is very fragile.
What are some of
the ways that you
think we, as conservatives,
can get around
the very obvious opposition
we face from big tech?
One of the thoughts
that I've had
is that attacks on the monopoly
status of many of these firms
is absolutely
necessary to ensure
that we have the platform to
be able to spread the message
like critical race theory.
Thank you.
CHRISTOPHER RUFO: Great.
Thanks.
Great question.
I think that the Disney
story is a perfect example
of a potential answer, or at
least a suggestion of answer.
One of the things
that I personally
like about the
governor of Florida--
and I've been able to
actually work with his team
on policy on some
of these issues--
is that he's not unwilling to
stand up to big companies, even
the big companies in his state.
I think he recognizes that our
corporations should ultimately
be serving the common good,
should be serving the country,
and he understands also that the
political power is ultimately
higher than business power.
And through the legislature, we
can set the rules of the game.
If there's anti-censorship
legislation,
I think there's some
commonsense regulation that
could happen to protect people.
Accepting that the digital
communications infrastructure
is the new public square or
the digital public square.
And I think you also
wield power, for example,
against a company like Disney.
If Disney is actively
undermining the families
and voters of, say,
Florida, I know
that I've been looking into
it, and Governor DeSantis
has been looking into it,
and Congressman Jim Banks,
for example, from nearby, in
Indiana, is looking into it--
well, let's see if we can level
the playing field a little bit.
Disney gets massive tax
breaks from Florida.
Legislators are
looking into those.
Congress has extended Disney's
copyright, essentially doing
their bidding, in perpetuity,
multiple times longer
than what the
founders had intended
in their 28-year
copyright limit.
And Republicans,
including Jim Banks,
have said, clearly, when
Disney's copyrights on things
like Mickey Mouse
expire next year
and they come, hat
in hand, to Congress,
saying, you better extend
it, you better extend it,
conservatives are
going to say, no,
we're not going to extend it.
We're going to
allow those things
to go into the public domain.
And so I think you
can, in some ways,
remind companies that the
deal that corporate executives
thought that they had
in the last few years
is we've already won
with conservatives.
We bought them off.
We have low tax rates.
We have competitive
economic environment.
It's better to be
a big corporation
than a sole proprietor or a
small business in the United
States.
And so we've bought them
off on economic issues.
We bought off the right.
And so we're going to buy off
the left on culture issues.
And they're finding out that
that relationship can shift
and the power can change.
And then you have wild
cards like Elon Musk.
I don't know anything
about him personally.
I never met him.
But I think there's
just a feeling right now
that we can tap into to maybe
channel that Teddy Roosevelt
spirit where we want to have
free enterprise, we want
to have free competition, but
what we don't want to have is
cartel organizations,
ideological and economic
cartels, dictating the
terms from up high down
to the average person.
And so I'm optimistic
about all that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
And I appreciate what you said.
I can't wait to
revisit it online.
But my wife and I
moved up here in 2013
to put our kids in
Hillsdale Academy
to get them out of the
public school system.
So I appreciate that.
We did what we
needed to do there.
And we did cancel our
Disney account this--
CHRISTOPHER RUFO: Well done.
AUDIENCE: --past week.
I've been needing
a reason to do it.
It's been itching.
But that's not what
I wanted to ask you.
I despise the term,
racism, because I
believe we're one race, right?
There's different counts of
melanin in a person's skin,
but we're one race.
And I despise that term,
because it breeds division.
And what would you
say-- how can we
overcome that particular term?
One of the beauties
of America's tapestry
is that we come from so
many diverse ethnicities,
and tribes, and nations, and
tongues, but we're one nation.
And what would you suggest?
CHRISTOPHER RUFO:
I would suggest
that the vast majority of people
agree with you in the sense
that we are one nation;
we come from all
over the planet, really a
unique composition of people;
and that we want to have
narratives, and especially
pedagogies, that inspire kids,
that help kids transcend maybe
their differences, aiming
them towards excellence,
aiming them towards their
greatest accomplishments.
And as you look at the public
polling data, it's very clear.
The Manhattan Institute
released polling data
from America's 20
fastest-growing cities.
These are places that
are very diverse,
there's a lot of
young families, people
trying to move their
way up the ladder,
live the American dream.
And the numbers were
quite clear among parents.
Parents opposed lessons
on critical race theory,
systemic racism, and white
privilege by, I believe,
a 42% margin--
overwhelming.
And this includes a majority
of parents who are white,
Black, Latino, Asian--
so a majority of every
racial demographic.
And they want to have
an education that
speaks to them the values of
all of these everyday people.
They said, look, I just want
to have my kid have a chance
to come up in the
world, to do better
than I could do, to get a great
job, to raise a great family.
And these are kind of the humble
but universal building blocks
that I see people
tapping into every day.
And they sense that
it's going to be crushed
by these people who occupy
positions of enormous power
and privilege that simply have
this poisonous and nihilistic
ideology--
wherever it comes from,
whatever its lineage is--
that they want to impose
from the top down.
And so I think the
best way to overcome
it is not to be a Pollyanna.
You have to acknowledge the
historical existence of racism
in the United
States, for example,
but always put it in the
context of the country's highest
ideals and the country's
steady progress
towards realizing them.
And I think it's a
unifying message.
And wherever I go,
people I talk to,
from all different
backgrounds, as long
as you're not at the New York
Times building or something,
it's something that
they want and they need.
And we have to be
unafraid to talk about it.
AUDIENCE: Chris, thank
you for your thoughts.
One of the things
that bothers me
is the total chaos
in the country.
I wouldn't trust the FDA,
the CDC, for sure the FBI
is equivalent to the
Gestapo, and maybe the CIA.
The military, I don't know
if they're for fighting a war
or fighting gender wars.
What do you think about
what's going on in society
beyond critical race theory?
It seems to be a total
meltdown of trust
in any of the institutions
on any of the issues,
be they science or whatever.
CHRISTOPHER RUFO: Yeah.
I think the answer
is pretty simple.
There's been a rupture
in trust because a lot
of the institutions
have been untrustworthy.
That's the simple fact.
I don't think that trust
numbers have plummeted
because our institutions have
been so wise, and virtuous,
and fantastic, and we're just
the ungrateful kind of plebs
below.
Look at COVID.
In a lot of cases-- this is
not my area of expertise--
but from just a
personal point of view,
all of these things that
were conspiracy theories,
so-called conspiracy
theories by "The Science,"
in capital letters,
turned out to be true,
whether it's the lab leak,
or whether it's, well,
you can't get COVID if
you have the vaccine,
or you can't pass it along,
or we need to have endless
masking, it's the
most effective plan,
you look at the politics that
has been embedded in all these
institutions, and then you
look at the decisions--
I think I saw the most
heartbreaking numbers,
for example, of businesses
that collapsed in the COVID
lockdowns.
Those are people's life
savings, their livelihood,
their whole dream, the whole
thing they've worked towards.
You have teenagers that lost
out on their high school
experience.
You have skyrocketing rates
of depression and suicide
among kids.
And then you turn around, as
parents are trying to say,
I'm trying to keep
a job, I'm trying
to keep my business
afloat, I'm trying
to make sure my kid doesn't
sink into the abyss,
I'm being lectured
on television,
and then I drop into my kids'
third-grade social studies
class, and he's being lectured
on critical race theory.
It's a very simple response to
people's everyday experience,
I think.
And it's too bad.
It's awful.
I've kind of learned
this maybe the hard way,
but these problems
aren't going to be solved
by asking, very
nicely and politely,
for the people in
positions of power
to pretty please
do a better job.
And you know what else is
something true, related--
[APPLAUSE]
I'll share an
experience from Disney.
The other thing that
we need to stop doing
is limiting our arguments
to things that are
deemed appropriate by liberals.
In journalism, you
wouldn't believe the kind
of self-censorship--
the biggest crisis
is self-censorship.
It's not even getting
banned from social media.
In the sense that, well--
I wrote the story
about, hey, what
is Disney's actual record
on child sex crimes?
Let's be honest about it.
You can't say that.
Oh, that's just
absolutely horrible.
That's out of bounds.
No, it's not.
And I think if we
internalize-- and it
depends on how online
you are, but there's
a kind of a classical liberal,
or a centrist liberal,
or a kind of Bill Maher type.
Appealing to people in that
category will get you nowhere.
And do you want to try to get
the plaudits or the approval
of people in that circle, in
the kind of left liberal media
environment and follow their
kind of rules of discourse,
and debate, and language?
Or do you want to actually
align with the 60% of people
who are fighting
for their companies,
fighting for their jobs,
fighting for their kids, that
are represented by
legislators at the state level
and the federal level
that are actually
going to get the job done?
And too many people in my world,
in my field of journalism,
they choose the former.
And I like to think that,
in 15, 20, 30 years,
they're going to realize,
wow, I was really
polite this whole time but
I didn't achieve anything.
And so I'd rather be impolite.
I'd rather get in a
little bit of trouble.
I'd rather make some of the
prominent people a little angry
and actually deliver results.
And so I think we're
doing that with Disney.
I think the story, for
example, with these videos,
it generated, at a bare
minimum, 100, 150 million media
impressions.
I think that it's
almost certain now
that Republicans in
Congress will not
extend their copyrights
next year when they expire.
That's a multibillion
dollar hit to Disney.
[APPLAUSE]
And you're not going to get
that done by being really polite
and following all the rules.
I hate to say it.
Sorry, kids.
Be polite, at Hillsdale,
to your teachers
and your administrators.
But out there, toughen up.
Right here.
AUDIENCE: How much
influence-- [? or ?]
mainly the 1619 Project that's
been an influence on CRT?
CHRISTOPHER RUFO: OK,
question, 1619 Project.
I've said this a
number of times--
the 1619 Project is
an epiphenomenon.
It is an ephemeral
creation that people
are going to forget about
in, probably, a relatively
short to medium period of time.
I don't think it
makes a lot of sense
to get too worked up about it.
I think that it can
displace a lot of attention
from the deeper issues about the
ideology, where it comes from,
how it works bureaucratically.
And I'm personally not too
worried about the 1619 Project.
I'm not saying it's good.
I don't like it.
But in the sense that I don't
think that the 1619 Project is
going to do grave
damage, I think
we have to really keep our eye
focused at a much deeper level.
And the question is, how do
you blow up the transmission
belt that delivers the
1619 Project to millions
of school kids?
And if you blow up
the transmission belt,
the New York Times is going to
be stuck with a lot of copies
of The 1619 Project.
LINNEA SHIVELY: We have
time for one more question.
CHRISTOPHER RUFO:
All right, great.
AUDIENCE: This question is about
blowing up that transmission
belt. Thank you for all you
do for opening our eyes.
CASEL, the social-emotional
learning company
that K-through-12
schools look to
for their
social-emotional learning,
they are now promoting equity
with excellence in education.
How do we crank out
more non-woke teachers
from our woke
universities and still
be able to label them
as excellence when
the academic world says, oh,
our public universities are
excellent and we have
to have certified?
Do we have a way to do that?
CHRISTOPHER RUFO:
Great question.
And we do.
There's a couple of ways.
I'll talk about maybe
the most effective way.
Look, I know Michigan is kind of
a purple state-- purple state,
would you consider it?
Yeah, OK.
But even red states--
I talk to people in
red states, how do we
deal with this horrible problem
of our public university
system?
I don't know.
You're the state legislature.
You pay for it.
You pass appropriations
bills for it.
It's under your jurisdiction.
And every year, you
just write a blank check
to the public university system.
These are public
universities that
should reflect and transmit
the values of the public
and the representatives
of the public, i.e.
state legislators, have ultimate
power to shape or reshape
those institutions.
And so we have to
get out of this idea
that somehow a public
university system is
a totally independent
entity that
practices academic freedom--
a total fraud.
That's just a false statement--
fundamentally false--
and that you can't
touch it or else you're
impinging on the rights of
the gender studies department
to follow their
dreams, you know?
It really is that simple.
And legislators you talk
to, they say, oh yeah,
I didn't think about that.
Because it's such in the
background of our experience.
We accept it as a given.
We accept it as the status quo
that we can't even examine.
But I think legislators
are starting-- in Florida,
they're doing it.
In Texas, they're doing it.
They're starting to
say, hey, wait a minute,
why is every taxi driver,
short order cook, and plumber
in my state paying six-figure
salaries for a diversity
and inclusion department at
a public university where
these folks are making
$300,000 or $400,000 a year,
and you look at their
job description,
it's indiscernible what they do.
You're funding private political
activism with public dollars.
So states can say, no more
public dollars for that.
You can take it away.
I think another thing that
states can do and should do
is saying, well, we're
going to actually open
a new branch of our
public university system--
say, the flagship University
of Michigan, Ann Arbor--
conservatives, let's
say, have both houses
and the governorship in
Michigan, for example--
a policy you could pursue.
We could say, we're going
to have an independent board
of directors, appointed
by the governor,
and we're going to have a
conservative center that
is independently governed within
the University of Michigan
or the University of Texas.
And then you create a magnet
for conservative professors,
you create a bit of debate
within the university,
you create a variety
of perspectives,
you create a
diversity of courses,
and you're creating a
separate patronage system.
Some people don't like
thinking about it that way.
But guess what?
The public universities, the DEI
departments, the public school
bureaucracies are, at
the end of the day,
patronage systems for
left-wing activists.
And as long as there's going
to be a patronage system,
wouldn't it be good to have
some people who are representing
the public within them?
I think the answer
is probably yes.
And for teachers specifically,
there's absolutely no reason
that teachers need
a master's degree
to teach reading
to third graders.
And in fact, all of the
academic studies, which
are by no means right-leaning
or conservative,
they show that
teacher credentialing
and teachers'
master's programs have
zero relationship with quality
teaching in the classroom.
And in fact, many people,
education scholars
whom I trust, say
that it actually
does significant damage to
the public school workforce,
because you have the
craziest people in charge
of departments of education--
I mean, really, truly.
The number one
most-assigned textbook
for graduate-level
departments of education
is a book called Pedagogy of
the Oppressed by Paulo Freire.
He was a Brazilian
Marxist-Leninist whose greatest
claim to fame was running
the educational propaganda
for the Marxist-Leninist
governments in West Africa
after decolonization.
And he very famously ran
the education program
for Guinea-Bissau, the
West African nation.
And some scholars went
back, years later,
and he was heralded as
this genius of education,
bringing education
to the countryside,
educating the peasants, Paulo
Freire's teaching everyone
to read.
They actually
studied the results.
They couldn't find
a single example
of a single person that
learned basic literacy
under his programs.
And guess what?
American public school
students are doing better
than the public school students
in Guinea-Bissau, for sure.
But you still have
about a quarter
of them never achieve basic
literacy, despite education
spending doubling or more in
the last generation or two
generations.
And so the simple
answer is, say,
from the state level,
pass legislation--
there is no financial
benefit and there's
no requirement for
teachers to get
advanced educational
credentials, degrees,
master's, et cetera.
And you can have someone
who's, say, a history
major at Hillsdale College
that is excited, wants
to learn how to teach,
can get a job teaching
history at a public school.
There's no reason
that you couldn't have
a system as simple as that.
And what that does is it cuts
out this cartel, essentially.
You have to pass through the
"graduate school of education"
cartel.
If you want your piece of
paper in order to teach,
you have to go
through their thing.
So they have a
captured customer,
a captured line of business.
Get rid of it.
Say, no more, statewide.
If you want to go, you can
go-- spend your own money.
It's not required.
And guess what?
I think nobody would go.
Maybe some lunatics would go.
And that's fine.
But then you look
at them and say,
don't hire the ones with
the master's, because those
are the crazies.
So I think a lot of it is, look,
public policy is the greatest
tool that we have.
Almost all of our problems
are created by public policy.
Almost all of the worst
ideologues in our society
are permanently subsidized
by public dollars.
And so we need to have the
courage, and the intelligence,
and the tenacity to say
what the public giveth
the public can taketh away.
And so we get in there, we
defund things we don't like,
we fund things we
do like, and we
try to break up the system
so that, ultimately, we're
taking power away from those
centralized authorities
and giving it back
to everyday people.
Because I spend a lot of time
at both parts of our society,
in the kind of fancy parts and
in the kind of everyday parts,
and at the end of the
day, I would trust people
in the middle, in
that big bottom,
making sane and rational
and wise decisions.
And so the more we can put
power into their hands,
the better we're going to be.
So I appreciate it.
Thanks, everyone,
for coming out.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thanks again, Chris.
For our guests, we
have a hospitality
just out here in the lobby.
If you leave hungry, it's
your own fault. For students,
go do your homework.
[LAUGHTER]